I've never seen dry ice deep fried so today. We're going to find out what happens if we do our setup is pretty basic
We've got a bunch of cooking oil on a hot plate. We've got some dry ice
And we're gonna try and combine them
But we do have a couple of things we want to try first before we go throwing our dry ice right into our super hot
Oil, I have a cup of this same cooking oil, but it's at room temperature
So I'm gonna try breaking off a piece of our dry ice dropping down into our cool oil
And we'll see what happens there after that we'll move up to using our hot oil there. Goes dry ice into regular temperature cooking oil
Well it's bubbling it's not doing nothing, but it's also
Not super exciting you can kind of see inside to cut that there is a little bit of a layer
That's formed the co2 gas coming off of dry ice has formed a sort of bubble around the chunk of dry ice
Inside the oil I also think that as the oil is
cooling down from the dry ice it's starting to get a little bit thicker a
Little higher viscosity, and it's definitely cool to the touch already like I can tell by holding this tough that the contents are quite cold
The oil just kind of runs right off of the oh look at this down inside though
You can see the yield oil. It's cooling down enough from the dry ice
We've got frozen new cooking oil there
And it's a Latin. It's not quite as thick as say butter or Crisco
It's clearly thick enough to hold yourself together so now moving on to the hot oil like I said
I don't know what's going to happen, and I know that oil can of course react violently with some things
I have here a little bit of water if I put in just a drop of that to the oil watch what happens
All of the water gets heated up and turns into steam
Which expands rapidly inside the hot oil so you get a lot of bubbling and splattering action from just one drop of water
Dry ice and water don't expand identically when they get heated up
So I'm not sure if the expansion of volume from the dry ice solid turning into a gas is going to have a similar effect
Or if it's just gonna be a little bit more calm and slow the way it was when we put it into the room temperature
Oil, that's why this is an experiment and we're about to find out oh
And I dropped it
Well it is bubbling quite a bit no explosions
Nothing violent splattering apparently these tongs aren't very good at holding onto chunks of dry ice
Fortunately I did have the tongs fairly close to the surface of the oil when it slipped out
Otherwise I would have had a much bigger splash even as it is some of the spilled on the plate
kind of want to try wiping that off because we're getting a lot of
very powerful fumes at this point
Doesn't help that our whole hot plate. Is that a little bit of an angle?
So the dry ice keeps making its way over to one side of the pot
And then it's also more full on that side of the pot so the bubbling makes it all splash over
That was a much larger chunk when we started this
I think that gave us some pretty good results of what happens if you drop dry ice into frying pot cooking oil
But there is another thing
I wanted to try some things when you deep-fry them aren't placed directly into the hot oil
Themself they're actually given something of a batter around them when you deep fry
So now we're gonna see what happens if we wrap a bit of dry ice in one of these biscuits
And then fry that in our cooking oil
We've got a little bit of biscuit
Break off piece of our dry ice a little bit big
Things we've got it pretty much in there and of course as soon as I get a good seal on the dough
it starts expanding inside the dough and just
Balloons up a little bit until a new spot opens up
so I don't think we're gonna be able to get a perfect seal on this because it just
Makes a new hole every time you've got it all perfectly sealed, but we'll try it. It's fairly well sealed up
Close it really well, and then slowly lower it in the oil you will see what happens when we deep-fry our dough covered
dry ice
Four more seconds looking at like a stone
No, I don't think there's a name for
Biscuit dough wrapped around dry ice and then deep-fried so we're gonna have to come up with a good name for this type of food
It's expanded quite a bit
I don't know if that's more from the heat of cooking or from the dry ice expanding thin so about this nice little
geyser
Coming out I'm also curious if it's cooked at all on the inside that cooked very quickly and of course
we know it was very cold on the inside as it was cooking so I'm
Thinking it might. Just have raw dough inside. You break this open into it with God oh?
Yeah, that is very raw on the inside
Super gross. I don't really want to eat
The raw dough here's a spot that looks like it's mostly cooked
Feel a little more lost effort there. We go this piece is all the way cooked all the way through so I'll try this
It tastes like fried dough big surprise you're gonna try turning down the heat just a little bit more and
Then I want to try this again to see if we can actually get a piece. That's cooked all the way through
It's also possible that it's just gonna stay so cold on the inside because of the dry ice it will never cook all the way
through
All right our oil. I think has cooled down a fair amount
It's still hot enough to fry
But it's not so hot that it's just gonna bubble and explode everywhere and cook the outside
Of our dough in five seconds like it did the first time it will still go fairly quickly
I think but I'm ready to try wrapping another piece of dry ice in here and
Hopefully we'll get a slightly more of thorough cooking
But it is as I said still possible that it's gonna be so cold on the inside
That the oil won't be able to get in there and really heat it up. Let's find out
It's definitely going slower than before which is a good thing because that way the heat will have more time to get
Inside the biscuit before it burns the outside
Last time our fry oil was so hot that by the time the outside was cooked it only been about five
Seconds per side so really didn't have any time to cook the inside dough
Looks pretty well cooked on the outside
Is that out see how it's done on the inside with our dry eyes
Mm-hmm you know it's still a little soft, and I wouldn't say it's finished, but it's a lot more cooked than
our first test or if not these scrap pieces
But it's a lot more cook than
This completely raw dough would like you it still would want a little more time
And I think the dry ice is preventing it from getting there
Maybe that's employer will you get on that side?
But it's definitely an improvement
Thanks for the heck of it. I'm gonna drop this back into the oil I'm gonna cook on the other side
Got one more piece I'm testing with a slightly smaller bit of dry ice
It's gonna. Let it sit in there
Maybe a little bit longer even until the outside is starting to look perhaps a little bit burned
Just because I want to see if we can actually get that inside to cook all the way through
Watch so very elated
It's good, but I think you probably squeeze oil out of it
Don't wear the glove you get just from picking it up at that time
hmm, okay
20 of co2 pumping its way out
Tried to let it get quite toasty on one side at least
they just open and see if you've got any extra poetry I
Don't know that's still pretty strange places
See how stretchy and youie that still is yeah, that's that's not cooked
There you have it a couple varieties of deep frying dry ice in hot oil when you put the dry ice directly into the oil
It does bubble and splash a little bit, but nothing very extreme
Not a lot more than you can put in a piece of bread dough or anything else that you would fry into more it is
maybe a little bit different than some things you would fry because it sinks all the way to the bottom of the oil so the
Bubbles have to travel all the way through the oil to the top what that happens with some foods as well
Overall I would say that it's a little bit neat to watch
But it's nothing very spectacular
Taking the dry ice and wrapping me up in some dough before we fry
It does of course give us a different result it seems to cook the outside of the dope well
But the cold food dry ice on the inside
Does seem to prevent the dough from cooking all the way through high heat?
It would just burn on the outside and stay raw on the inside
slightly lower and slower heat
It would cook a little bit more of the way through but the part of the dough that was really in
Contact with the dry ice never seemed to change texture, and it doesn't seem like they would be safety
remember if you have any cool ideas for an experiment you want to see us try and let us know down in the comments and
If we use your idea, we'll send me 25 bucks this has been a fun experiment for us
Thank you user Rivas for your recommendation check your youtube inbox. We're sending you 25 bucks
Thanks for joining us for this video today and remember to come gear yourself up with hats shirts and other cool merch at the king
Of random calm see you there
Blob solidified gelled oil hmm. That's cold. That is so cold don't flip yourself over
Today we've got a comment request from user rep beep
Hey guys, if you want to catch up with some of the things I'm doing in my personal life
Come follow me on Instagram and Twitter at the king of random
I post stories and updates as often as I can and its really the best way to connect with me directly
You